[Music]
admit it one of the best moments in
action anime is when a character just
simply for lack of a better term
doesn't give a damn about his opponent
it doesn't matter how strong the
opponent is or how many enemies there
are you have one
overpowered character put a one-man army
or just assert complete dominance on any
opponent
it's one of the most satisfying feelings
that caused the popularity of
overpowered main characters in my
opinion you're in for a treat today
because we'll be taking a look at 10
anime moments where a character just
simply showcases his powers if you're up
for some top tier flexing
you've come to the right place we start
off with levi taking on
the beast titan
there are many things that levi is cool
powerful
resourceful relentless amongst others
now what happens if you put all of those
together
in one short package the ultimate titan
killing machine that's what he's had a
lot of great moments that got fan girls
wet but what bigger showcase of power
than his jewel with the beast titan for
all the hype that the beast titan got
he sure fell rather quickly to levi
technically levi didn't do this alone
and the meticulous dissection of the
beast titan would never have been
possible
without major sacrifices however once
the stage has been set and levi was let
loose
it was over the beast titan didn't know
what hit him and before long were
treated to one of the most elaborate
destructions of a titan in the entire
series the precision and flow in which
levi goes to work is just
impeccable and it truly shows why he's
called humanity's strongest soldier
[Applause]
[Music]
coming up next is datsuya's material
burst
[Music]
so when political warfare gets serious
things become
well quite complicated especially if
you're talking about
an entire alliance of enemies led by not
china in the mahoka verse thankfully
japan has something that any other
nation in the world doesn't have
godzilla heck why risk having the enemy
forces land and start a bloody war that
will guarantee
uncountable casualties just blast the
entire fleet and evaporate them while
they're still at sea watch out that
tsuya does it from the comfort of a far
away military base
material burst as they call it is one of
the most powerful forces of destruction
in the mahoka universe tatsuya at this
point in the series has had a lot of
these moments already there was a time
he knocked someone out by staring at him
or that one time he melted a bus on the
road from inside a classroom oh and
there's beating a sniper using his
pistol but none of them
comes close to this one in terms of
scales
foreign
a second light novel protagonist makes
his way to the list and we have
arnos coming in next
[Music]
you know how you being the strongest
demon lord ever showcase your power to
your weak descendants by first killing
someone without even lifting a finger
over and over and over again not done
having fun
arnos revives it doesn't matter that the
poor victim seems to have these cool
powers or can make some brave speeches
that you typically hear from powerful
opponents
somehow there's a twisted sense of
satisfaction seeing arnold's just cake
walk over the opposition then willingly
bring him back just to make a statement
ah just the perfect moment to set up and
give your viewers expectations as to
what misfit of demon king academy is i'd
say that this is an exaggerated parody
of the magic academy light novel genre
kind of like what one punch man is to
superhero and shonen series
a short turn your brain off series that
you might enjoy so do check it out
let's continue with more heroic examples
with eskanor given the seven deadly sins
reputation as a shown in series where
everyone's power limiters just get taken
off and allowed to run wild i expected
something from the show to make its way
to the list the main problem is however
was picking the right moment to feature
because there are so many of them after
careful deliberation
my personal favorite showcase of power
you'll see out of the series is esknow's
battle against two commandments galland
and molescular
all the trash talking and the showcase
of power by those two may seem
impressive at first glance and not to
eskina
after all of that all they managed to do
is a puny cut and when it's eskenore's
turn
consider the battle finished the result
well a perfect victory escond comes out
of the two-on-one completely uninjured
i'd call this one of the biggest flexes
in all of seven deadly sins and seeing
as we're talking about eskimo i guess
that that statement can be taken a
little bit more literally a supposed
boss fight that gets wrapped up in a
little less than two chapters in the
manga and a couple of minutes in the
anime hilarious part
that's eskino for you
when you think of overpowered anime
protagonists luffy doesn't offer make
the list immediately i mean that's fair
compared to a lot more of the more
modern protagonists or even some of his
peers in his era luffy's taking quite a
bit of losses and had to struggle to get
the wins he got that way of writing a
protagonist does make the triumphs mean
more but it also makes moments like
these a breath of fresh air the visual
of luffy not batting an eye as he gets
surrounded by hordes of fish men is
something that i won't easily forget
it's also mainly because of how he just
beats them all you know how in anime
numbers often mean nothing here
it's one against fifty thousand rookie
numbers i say especially if you've got
conquerors haki on your side luffy just
walks over these fish men like it was
nothing not even throwing a punch
defeated them all in an instant granted
these fishermen are nothing but mooks
but for the people in the one piece
universe that's still fifty thousand of
them that's gotta mean something right
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
up next we have muzan killing the lower
moons i think that the scene of a
villain killing his minions for their
weakness has become quite common however
what's less common is the villain doing
so
just because muzan does that in short
order you remember that lower moon that
gave our heroes trouble
of course you do half of you probably
got into demon slayer because of the
episode where tanjiro fights the guy
now imagine multiples of them and muzon
just easily disposes of them without
batting an eye all because
he wanted to or because he found them
weak given what happened
i don't think muzan's lying was it a
smart decision for the leader of the
demons
most likely not was it a big ball's flex
of power
yes it definitely was all of them just
outright dropped dead without us even
knowing what they can do
breaking the shonen rule at least one
lower moon lives through it all and
you'd expect to have to see the upcoming
movie to fully experience the true
ferocity of n-move
[Music]
we have a recent contender making the
list jujutsu kaizen's gojo
those of you watching the currently
airing anime would have probably heard
of the tale of gojo sensei and his
amazing battle against dogo personally i
think that the battle perfectly fits
into this list as it shows the
terrifying extent of gojo's powers in
order to push him as arguably one of the
most overpowered characters on the list
at first you would have thought that
jojo would put up any semblance of a
fight
and for a brief moment he does and
that's all there is to it what happens
next is basically an exhibition
an example to tell you why you pick your
battles and never
ever go after the happy-go-lucky teacher
with such a fierce reputation let's just
say that jojo got owned there's no other
way around it he's not known as the
strongest sorcerer for nothing
now whose brilliant idea was to give
such a cool character the broken ability
of space manipulation
[Applause]
foreign
when utsuru was introduced where he
kicked our main cast ass i mean beating
those guys without breaking a sweat is
no easy feat but what if he starts
taking on the entire freaking cast of
the show
still not a challenge utsuru is right up
there in the gallery of most broken
anime antagonists and the decisive fight
against him is basically a showcase of
how insane this guy
is kintoki gets stomped pretty easily
but then the shin sengumi comes in and
gets their ass kicked as well even kamui
and umiboz are no match for him with all
these opponents giving their best shots
usoro still stands proud and tall
wrecking everyone like it was nothing
we're just getting started with a whole
slew of showden villains however
coming up next should be another very
familiar face granddaddy of broken
shonen anime villains
eisen is a must include on this list
when the fake garage arc was ongoing in
bleach you'd really wonder how much of a
war it really was it's only one side
getting casualties and aaron cars while
putting up a fight generally looked
outmatched once the vaisards come in
it's virtually
game over it seems but let me ask you a
question when were you under the
impression
that eisen needed help at his state he's
become the sheer embodiment of an
overpowered villain evolving and getting
new powers with every fight the illusion
powers on his zambach though is already
troublesome but now you throw in super
regeneration and new ways of surviving
whatever nukes thrown at him into the
mix outsmarting and soloing multiple
captains is something but even tanking
everything that urahara and friends have
in store
just absurd take even ichigo's super
ultimate final attack gets tanked later
on granted it was mostly post-training
ichigo flexing on him that fight
but it just gives a perspective of what
level eisen's at
[Music]
of course we can't have eisen without
the other broken shonen jump villain
madara far too often in anime we see a
villain with tons of hype for all the
time he was off screen
he gets talked about as some super
powerful force only to get beaten rather
easily once it's his time to actually
appear
none of that applies to madara he hit
the road running with his first
appearance being one of the biggest
one-man army moments in all of anime
he's just far too strong for the lowly
shinobi alliance which he systematically
takes down all by himself the guy is
the most broken character in the entire
series and it's not even close i'm
pretty sure kishimoto created the whole
kaguya thing because he realized that he
made madala too powerful and needed to
come up with a beatable villain i think
i made this joke somewhere before
and i still stand by it with that we
conclude this list
so what do you think about it which one
would you rank at the top and which
would you rank higher or lower perhaps
you also have moments that you think
should have belonged to the list the
comment section is all yours if you have
any suggestions for future content that
you want to feature
make sure to also drop this in the
comments as well i might take a look at
the most
interesting ones and create a featured
list on that sooner rather than later as
we finish i encourage you to like and
subscribe if you're interested in more
videos please hit the subscribe button
because nothing makes me happier than
seeing this channel grow
let's work together for our next
milestone and i'll see you next time
on vinnie tube
you